former Vice President Joe Biden is
defending the Obama administration after
his rivals for the Democratic nomination
criticized its record on health care and
immigration in Wednesday's presidential
debate ed O'Keefe is covering the road
to 2020 and what does the former
president say about these attacks
well good morning Anthony a source
familiar with mr. Obama's thinking tell
CBS News he's not concerned about his
legacy and still has no plans to
campaign with any candidate this year
in the meantime Democratic candidates
face a long month of campaigning before
the next debate in September hoping to
build momentum from this week's debates
Massachusetts senator Elizabeth Warren
rallied supporters in Arizona last night
promising action on climate change gun
control and immigration we need big
change in this area you know where it
needs to start we need to expand legal
immigration in this country candidates
like Senator Cory Booker know August is
a crucial month to build support for
their campaigns that's why they'll make
stops in the coming week in the early
states Iowa and Nevada former Texas
congressman Beto O'Rourke is already in
Las Vegas spending time with potential
voters and not losing sight of the
upcoming September debate in his home
state we qualified for the September
debate in Houston I'm super excited to
be there O'Rourke is one of only eight
Democratic candidates who has already
met the requirements to take part in a
third round of debates scheduled for
next month at least two candidates are
close to qualifying to make the debate
stage candidates must hit at least 2% in
four national polls and raise money from
at least 130 thousand unique donors
candidates who haven't yet met the
threshold including New York senator
Kirsten Gillibrand have until the end of
the month to do something I'm looking
forward to September
I keep working hard to lift up my vision
for the country and why I'm unique
frontrunner Joe Biden is several steps
ahead confident he can take back key
battleground states that helped
President Trump win in 2016 if I get the
nomination
I will win Michigan I promise you that I
will win Pennsylvania I will win Ohio
despite the attacks on mr. Obama's
record during the debates the former
president still polls very well with
members of his own party a recent CBS
News poll last Democrats about him and
found that nearly 60% of Democrats rated
his tenure as quote excellent so any
candidate likely attacks his legacy at
their peril Michelle good point and
thank you